it's all about the people the company is
not me it's the team
it's everything about the team that is
being built their motivation their
inspiration
what do they do
[Music]
benny charney thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders
michael thanks for having me benny i i
just want to hear about your journey
i it's very rare to meet a founder
that bootstrapped a company from their
living room as an engineer
and grew it to over a thousand customers
some of the most notable companies that
we all know here in the us
but more importantly you're providing
cyber security systems uh for
98 percent of the us nuclear facilities
is that right that's correct actually
that's just one example so we we protect
our mission is to protect critical
infrastructure
i mean yes nuclear facility is one of
the there's one testimony of our success
however we do everything we do
government we do
manufacturing agriculture utilities
other energies
it's not only nuclear there is also
renewable with
solar that we said there is taunts uh
benny i'm starting with the most
important question do you sleep at night
i mean seriously aren't you like scared
about what you're doing this is crazy
i sleep i sleep really well at night i
mean it will be very rare occasions that
i don't kind of don't sleep well at
night i like to sleep well at night and
i think that's uh wonderful okay benny
take me back
take me back to the founding days of of
upswat
how does it start and and sort of what
is your strategy in in
in building this company which now is
huge huge success
great thank you uh so how it started so
it all started with an idea and a vision
right everything starts there
so also think about the person what do
you want to do so
you want to go i mean i i knew i mean
actually if you asked me when i was
i think it was sixth grade what you
gonna do
i could tell you i'm gonna go and build
a cyber security company when i was six
i went
and and it was funny actually i still
have a childhood friend was still
battling that and we kind of could still
find oh i'm gonna have a
better company i'm gonna have a better
company i'm gonna be
it's still happening by the way he also
he founded again that founding another
company and in civil engineering and we
are still having that
today it was still kind of amazing
laughing at us amazing okay so you have
this vision you have this strategy
you're going to build a cyber
security company but you do it in a very
unorthodox way because today is diverse
every you know
engineer out of 8200 wants to build a
cyber security company
raises a 10 million dollar seed goes to
series a and sells it for 200 million
dollars
you did something else yeah so what i
did i bootstrapped it
so i start with first the goal what was
the the
global mission i said hey what kind of
okay let's see what do i have here and
when i when i started the company it was
i knew okay fine i'm gonna go and put
something together i'm gonna go in
and do it and i'm gonna make it could i
raise money in 2002 yes i could
if i wanted to i would focus on that
however i found myself much more
battling between selling the products to
customers
willing to already use the product and
appreciate it
to spending my time actually talking to
the investors and at some point i said
you know what
i'm gonna go and try take it the hard
way and then
go all the way without kind of without
anything
anything else it's not like a invested
capital so initially what i did i
i provide some professional services not
in that area
in other and i use that fund of
professional services to hire engineers
to go and build the product
i start eventually with one after that
then one became two two became four
four became eight and so on and so wow
so there's no institutional funding
throughout the lifetime of opswat
no not yet no unbelievable okay now talk
to me a little bit about about the
journey so now you have
over a thousand customers you're
handling over 98
of of the nuclear facilities in the u.s
how do you get
to a level where you're building the
trust where the u.s government
is letting you defend its most critical
infrastructure
i mean that sounds to me that sounds
like like the highest level you can get
to
as a cyber security company yeah so it's
all depends upon
that my three operating principles so
number one is the
technology being committed to the
technology yeah
i would hope so yeah number two
yeah number two is very much the the
the people on the team it's all about
the people and
the company is not me it's the team it's
everything about the team that is being
built
their motivation their inspiration what
do they do
whenever they kind of whatever we think
whenever they go and
what keeps them up is how to make sure
the product is competitive the product
is doing what it's supposed to do
we are very transparent about the
product how from end to end from
marketing through the how the product is
operating right
we go to market the channel the how we
go
and very much selling the product out
there
how we how we reach out to to these
folks it really needs
right so how many so so how many people
are are involved in this right now
with opswat in the company we have 321
employees today
incredible they're growing actually we
have 30 open positions despite the
corona we are hiring
30 open positions yeah that's so you're
you're looking to grow 10 percent during
covet 19. yes we are yes we are we are
not i mean critically i'm talking to our
customers i'm talking customers in
anywhere they are going to the office so
in the center
most of our customers we still have some
customers end of the day we are building
a great product we have some awesome
non-traditional critical infrastructure
companies buying our solutions so that
they're not bank
they are not energy not utility not
still bank because we're a good product
although most of our customers are
actually going to the office
incredible okay so you know i have quite
a few friends who who have either lost
their
internship or lost their job offer
because things have been have
have have gone erased so so definitely
uh
this sounds great but benny talk to me a
little bit about
about the cyber security space i want to
i want your earned
secrets over these years of building up
spot you're dealing with
some of the most incredible companies
and you really are an expert in the
cyber security field simply because
you've been
selling in the field and you've been
developing cr cutting edge technology
there
what what what is the cyber security
space today like
in the world and what are the biggest
challenges that we're heading towards
okay so if you're looking at the cyber
security from uh
that is very segregated i mean if i'm
looking at companies
very separate i see very very good
companies however sometimes doing just
one point solution yeah i create a very
good
email security i create a really good
antivirus or a
different point solution and and if
you're looking at the cyberhead and i
keep
saying you see like more than 3000 cyber
security companies out there
maybe 500 are in israel and then you
have like kind of
so right and then you see that so what
what what is missing from that
perspective so okay
what's unique about us is very much a
critical infrastructure protection it's
holistic view on critical infrastructure
we have two platforms that helps you not
only prevent
threats also create a process so
whenever we research cyber security
attacks it's all about
it's not only about okay defending it's
also creating a process we go to
to csos to it managers we ask them
who is bringing data who is bringing
devices
what type of data do you have a policy
you'll be surprised that there is no
single answer and we are there to go and
solve this problem
another operating principle that i've
seen is that
there is not enough education system so
there is no training
there is no official training there it
could be a training for a product
though there is no training for the
problem and what you are trying to
achieve
right so on that also for example we're
investing a lot in uh we call it the
opposite academy so it's all about
training the the i.t folks for the
critical infrastructure
now i don't want to promote it to be
here just to promote
use that amazing time just to promote
the company though he asked me about how
i see the cyber security
market so i find very segregated very
points focused very product focused
not too much solution for the focus
obviously you have the big folks you
have the
the checkpoint of the world you have the
the palo alto of the world you have the
sister of the world and you say oh we do
everything
so in cyber security so this is more
than
the militaries you need some security
you get the military and then you have
the point solution that
is most like the products folks that's
something that the company is
doing something specific something's
very good or one one
one thing or sometimes two things that
are repeating and and getting in in the
starbucks in the cyber security
field benny but it it sounds to me you
know i'm coming from the cyber security
space myself
but and one of the things that i that i
learned quickly in my time in 8200 is
that this world is changing
constantly it's a it's a cat and mouse
game
and new and new things are coming up all
the time new technologies
for every new device that you know today
our our fans are connected
and i believe one of the you know really
mind-changing moments that i had was
back in my course in the army and we had
a guest speaker who came in and show and
explain and showed us a paper that they
wrote in the technion
of how a ceiling fan can actually
transmit data
that you wouldn't expect it to and i was
thinking to myself a ceiling fan
can can give me information a critical
information about
about whatever's happening and i thought
that was crazy so how do you
manage that new knowledge that is
constantly being creating because
you know you're only relevant as long as
you're up to date with what's happening
you have to be ahead of of everybody
else in the game right
oh that's a good one so for that we keep
innovating so to a point that we keep
having new products so
later during the coffee 19 we released
three new products
so to a point that we are we are well
doing it so i completely agree with you
it's keep changing
the threats landscape keep changing so
there's something else interesting that
i've seen
in cyber security sometimes it's
revolving so what you've seen that you
know
something that was happening 10 years
ago is coming back to life sometimes
interesting for example with for example
data loss prevention and some other
technologies that
are keeping reinventing themselves and
the reason for that is that
the it the i.t is changing and then
security needs to catch up with a new id
threat so for example mobile phones for
example
iot devices so the reason for that is
that
the idea what we do how we interact uh
work from home for example is a
it's a different attack vector for both
productivity and
and and security of course so that's
that's now with the copy that will
accelerate
activities and progress programs around
interesting okay and you know
how do you create a culture though where
people are
interested in learning so instead of
just continuing to develop the current
software they're continuing to research
and understand
what else is happening is there do you
do deploy that through a specific
division that is responsible for new key
findings
or for learning or do you collaborate
with with academia and and universities
to see what what they're coming up with
how do you maintain the number number
one in the game
okay so so there are multiple answers
for that number one is our customer
landscape we have so many deployments
actually it's over 1500 customers to be
to be uh to be precise um so we have
lots of customs and lots of probes out
there
every customer could deploy our product
in multiple our
products some of them has i mean you can
enable sensors to go and
understand what's happening there and
and with customers if they'd like to
share the threats with us
we get a lot of data from first our
customers and they see what's what's
happening
number two we have our own big data
analysis so big data analysis we have
meta defender cloud you can go and share
data there and imagine the cloud we have
tons of users we have a whole community
of motors they're just
they're talking about number three we
have a model sharing program with very
much
almost every antivirus out there so
whatever for example
a vendor hire center center one
semantic mccarthy all of these folks
that are finding a threat we are obliged
to go and share
threats with each other so we research
them okay and
another thing that i'm seeing by the way
in in in the cyber is related to that
is that also related to the philosophy
and also
a bit about our success is our
technology philosophy is truly zero
thrust so we assume
all of the files are bad this is why we
generate them
so however that's kind of that's another
kind of operating
philosophy and we test the moving
landscape and the moving targets and the
the moving threads to to our kind of
dual code
i love it benny i want to move a little
bit to the entrepreneurial journey and
and leadership and and i'd love to know
er you know the traditional path that i
see here
is in in the valley in tel aviv is that
you go you raise institutional funding
and you move quickly and when you get to
ring the bell
at nasdaq like lemonade is doing today
even though this is going to be
going to be shown to the public later on
but today the lemonade is going public
that's sort of the lifetime dream of any
entrepreneur it doesn't seem like that
is necessarily your
ambition and your dream what is your
consideration for keeping the company
private rather than public and and do
you ever see yourself
going on to something else so back to
your question actually
like no it's like there is a chance
we'll go either public or
there is a big a big or could be a big
exit to
could be a big merger with something or
i don't operate this way first
i build a company to last i bet the
company loves with a good culture with a
good team with a good management team
with a good business
and that's kind of where i get what
what's in for the
employees and everything first the
equity that i provide to the team
members is much better than you know
diluting it with
with some busy folks right now and i can
present
the numbers and whenever i keep asking
don't look at the quantity of the stocks
look at the value it will bring you in
the case of an exit
right and then uh so i have team members
with stock or stock options depends on
the their situation in that and i
i believe that at some point whether we
decide to go to the ipo road or we
decide to
uh to remember to get the partner with
the private equity to go and get it
which is uh
another one so i built the company to
last
i think that i mean that's the most
inspiring part you're building the
company to last i think right now
you know especially what i'm saying with
with a lot of my colleagues
in my age group is that you're not
thinking about a company that you're
going to be involved with for 10 15 20
years
you think about products that you're
going to be excited to work on for a
year
or two and then sell or move on to your
next project which is a very different
mindset
benny you moved from managing a
one person yourself basically to now
managing over 300 people
in this great company what have you
learned over the years or what surprised
you
over things that you didn't expect well
it's cool but initially i was very much
sure everything i was the
the bigger guy i was the recorder
i was pretty much the you know the hr
the everything around it and then slowly
get get the
management team a professional
management team in place uh
the right system in place the backend
systems in place to go and put it
together to a point that it's
and i see this journey that you're
challenging me from okay from doing what
and it's actually changing my kind of my
day today and i find it very fascinating
i love it
so i find myself as a you know building
careers and building careers inside the
company
i mean i i tell my executive teams two
things you have two honorable ways to go
and leave the company two honorable ways
option one you die it's honorable right
option number two go open your own
company right
and by the way it worked with two
executives two past executives i mean
they didn't die they opened their own
company
amazing successful what i would like to
see here you'll come over here where we
walk together as a team
and after that you know build your
experience and then after five years to
win the building company i'm still in
touch with them
great this is what i call an honorable
way i love it
benny what would be the most important
thing that if
for you that if i would ask any of your
300 employees
i i tell them tell me one the the best
thing about benny
what would they tell me about your
leadership style because you know i'm
looking i'm
getting information from myself i want
to be an entrepreneur myself one day or
continue being an entrepreneur and
create my own company
and i'm thinking what what are the most
important traits that i need to maintain
or or uphold as a leader all right so
um i'm i'm personable so i'm connecting
with whenever i connect i'm connecting
with you
talk to me you are yeah so i'm very
personal
i'm very direct to say hey i hate it i
like you
i think you are not doing it and i think
that when you match that with the
personable then
they don't take it personally because
you're you care for them it's your the
feedback you're giving them is not
against them it's
perhaps critical it's perhaps criticism
over the work
but but because you build this personal
trust then it's much more meaningful to
be direct right
yeah so that's kind of that's that's on
this one and direct and so on and then
i like to start to ask why why
what's in for you on on that so can i to
that that point
um also i'd like to understand what they
like to do what they don't like to do
people usually they are good usually not
always they are good at what they like
to do right so that's kind and they like
to take jobs and things that are good at
and i'm trying to
to just ensure it's there and then to to
provide
i've managers that have been with me for
many years in the silicon valley which
is tough
right many of us will be for 12 years so
there is
one is going to go and retire an
executive gonna retire from the company
i see it oh that's
i look at it as an accomplishment
incredible i mean i think i think it's
i think it's amazing amazing that you're
looking at that as you know a source of
accomplishment for the company
uh i don't think that many founders and
leaders
would see that as like as such such a
great accomplishment
obviously it is but i think just their
focus may be on other things
but it sounds like you're putting the
team first which i think is so so cool
what is it about the the culture that's
that's making them want to stay for so
long because opportunities here are
endless there's constant competition
for the best talent especially coming
out of it of a great company like yours
so what what do you think makes people
want to remain strong within a company
that like offspot so number one is our
mission right
you want to identify yourself with a
mission company really helps somebody
right so you're not going to go and
you're not you know
again there are some you're not selling
you're not doing something you're doing
good you're not doing something bad
right perceives to be bad by by some uh
so there is very pure mission uh number
two the
the commitment of the company to the
technology and the product something
that is thriving with people
it's uh yeah we yes we want to create a
great product what
what i want the guy to to if there's
something bothering them is what
the how what's going to be the customer
experience definitely
end of the day i'd like the the team
members to think about the
people likes that they're connect
they're connecting to right
in very transparent sculptures so the
team members they know okay we're making
numbers what's that
kind of we usually make the numbers and
then we usually exceeded
exceed them so it's very transparent and
also it's also keeping a message of
success
no no i think that is so small there
which also tells about
a lot of predictions so whenever we are
providing a focus
not only to ourselves also to our
vendors and also to
internally to to to to sales team
members and to product managers
who like to be very honest with the
numbers and every once in a while
yourself and very transparent to
ourselves and then
if you can't put together a forecast
don't put it there
right i think and that's that i think
something is that that a lot of young
entrepreneurs need to need to uphold and
learn
especially in today's age benny before
we leave 20 minutes go by so fast i want
to thank you for your time and your
generosity
and you know you we know each other from
j ventures and it's been it's been great
working over there and we we met in
person right before the start of corona
and i look forward to seeing you again
in person
in the monthly meetings after corona but
before we leave i need three words that
best describe you
oh the hardest question
oh and you're asking me to describe
myself usually i'm going to ask you hey
go ask others what to say about you know
what i'm going to go back and i'm going
to ask
if i were to ask any of your 300
employees or your 1500 customers
who is benny what are the three
characteristics that that he is
most representative as okay so he's
definitely a builder a builder of
technology and an
innovator so definitely would say that
you know we are
very much kind of innovative the
platform that is not like another
category other in the market that is
successful in a career builder
yeah some building careers and then
people and also yeah career builder as
well i would say that they would
i i think i can stand behind that and
provide
it definitely sounds like it um the
third one ouch
you know i think that it's amazing that
you're thinking critically about this
because you know
a lot of people they they know
immediately and they're saying you know
like these interview questions but i
think
that you're you're so humble and and
you're really you know you're
you're thinking about the 300 people
that you have and you're building this
great great company
and to it exudes from this conversation
how you're putting so much focus
on the career building and the success
of your customers and the success of
others along with you
you're not just thinking about how can i
make it the biggest but how can i build
a culture and how can i build a team
that is really proud of what we're doing
and i think that that speaks for itself
so i'm going to be great with two words
with that description at the end so and
i really want to thank you for this
inspiration
really thank you michael for the
opportunity to speak here and i
appreciate your time
of course no thank you and i'm going to
reach back of course when i have my own
venture and i can't wait to work
together in the future
i'm looking forward to it take care bye